do not be alarmed  you do not know me  i am communicating with you right now to  convey a message a message that if  ignored  will spell the end of your race as you  know it  due to a recent turn of events within s  scp foundation  critical points in time have been  scrambled and moved out of  synchronization  there is a storm  coming  an entity previously thought manageable  will prove itself to be anything but  this would not be preventable without  foresight  but i am here to gift you that advantage  if you forget anything  from this message do not let it be this  you must contact a specific individual  within the foundation  if you are unsure as to who this is  i will leave you with this  set the gears in motion  before it is too late  you